[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact in November 1939
a young Polish lieutenant Slava me
Rawat's was arrested by the Russians
following the German Soviet invasion of
Poland following 12 months of
interrogation he was sentenced to 25
years hard labor for a bogus charge of
spine and sent off to Siberia with
thousands of others Slav was transported
in an open cattle truck in sub-zero
temperatures to the end of the line at
accoutns at that point the wretched
prisoners were chained together and
forced to march hundreds of miles to
camp 303 which the survivors then had to
build for themselves from scratch in
April 1941 with the aid of the camp
commandant wife Slav and six others
escaped in a blizzard for the next year
they trekked 4,000 miles living off the
land through the Gobi Desert and over
the Himalayas on through Tibet until
they reached India where they were
discovered by some Gurkha patrols three
of the seven died on the way when
rescued Slav weighed only 70 pounds but
he went on to live to the age of 88
through sheer determination he and three
others had survived bitter cold
suffocating heat thirst starvation and
major injury in their epic quest for
freedom did you know that the central
message of the Bible is about a
pilgrimage to freedom stay with his
friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 do have some
lines open so pick up the phone if it
rings for a minute just be patient and
our operators will pick it up and
they'll ask you a few practical
questions and get you queued up and then
we'll put you on the air and in the
order and one more time 804 6 3 7 2 9 7
my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross good evening listening friends
we want to welcome you all to again
Bible answers live and our Facebook
friends who are joining us we also want
to greet you thank you for tuning in if
you would like to call in with your
Bible question the phone line again is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven faster days probably a good
time to start the program with prayer
dear Father in Heaven we thank you once
again that we have this opportunity to
study a word and we just ask for your
continued guidance as we search the
Scriptures be with those listening we
ask this in Jesus name Amen amen
ambassador you open the program our
telling this rather remarkable story of
endurance and just undying determination
for freedom traveling more than 4,000
miles on
foot through the terrible terrain trying
to find freedom that is some of the most
desolate country on the planet if you
look at a map and you can find a map
online of where they walked I mean
walking across Siberia and then they ran
into a big lake one of the biggest lakes
in the world they had to go hundreds of
miles around this lake and then through
the Gobi Desert and through the high
ranges of Tibet and is amazing that
Slavonia was able to help them he had
learned how to trap when he was young
and he helped them trap and fish and
they just lived on a pretty meager diet
but they were so determined to be free
that they avoided revealing themselves
to anybody until they got all the way to
India where they knew that they might
find some English that would sympathize
and so it's just an amazing story and
you know it makes me think about in the
Bible where it tells us that the message
of Scripture is one of a people that are
searching for freedom the whole message
of the exodus is people leaving their
bondage their slavery their and going to
the promised land the place of freedom
you've got so many stories of people
like Joseph who go from the prison to
the palace and Peter saved from prison
and Paul saved from prison and you know
Daniel save from the Lions Den so this
is a message of what God also wants to
do for us and friends if you'd like to
know more about how you can experience
that freedom we've got a very special
book that even talks about Siberia it is
a book entitled Death Watch in Siberia
and it's really talking about just the
good news of salvation and the
experience that God sustained those who
chose him how God sustained in through
some difficult trials it's a great read
a great testimony I'm again called death
watch in Siberia and for anybody who
would like to receive that give us a
call on our resource phone line and
we'll be happy to send that to you the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and you can ask for our free offer
tonight which is Death Watch in Siberia
alright pastor doc I think we're ready
to go to the phone lines our first
caller this evening
is Kim listening in Wisconsin ken
welcome to the program hi pastor Roggin
class of duck I had a question on mark
10:18 okay yeah where Jesus say why do
you call me good no one is good except
God along so you know they think does
that mean Jesus wasn't good well first
of all the Bible says every good and
perfect gift is from God and Jesus was
God the Son and he was good and he is
God's gift as well Jesus was not saying
I'm not good he was trying to help the
young man see that he is God because
jesus said you're calling me good all
men have fallen and sinned but maybe I'm
the only reason that I could be good is
if I'm from the father I am God God the
Son and so he wasn't denying his
goodness he was trying to impress the
young man with his godness you see what
I'm saying yeah well do you think Jesus
was good yeah he's good yeah and so this
young man he's looking for eternal life
and he said why do you call me good
there's no one good except God and so
he's basically saying you know I was
there in the beginning I'm the one who
declared all things good at creation now
doesn't the Bible say that all things
that were made were made by Jesus in the
beginning was the word and then God when
he created everything declared it good
and you know God is good the Bible says
so yeah Jesus wasn't denying that he was
good he was just trying to help that
young man recognize that he wasn't just
a good master he calls him good teacher
he was more than a teacher he was God
and you know I have a free book I can
send you on that subject talks about the
divinity of Christ and it's called the
Trinity is it biblical if you like free
copy of that we'll send that to you and
I'm the Col deze 883 five six seven four
seven and again you can ask for the book
called the Trinity is it biblical we'll
be happy to send them out to anybody who
calls and asks I Mexico Lee's Michael
listening from
Sippi Michael welcome to the program hi
well my question is uh I wonder what
kind of Transportation is going to be in
heaven is gonna be like I know a lot of
people who love cars and an earth today
so what about in heaven will it be any
kind of transportation like cars on a
new earth cars of motorcars well I'll
tell you Pastor Ross and I were just
talking about race cars before we went
on the air it's a special love of his I
think that we're going to be able to
build all kinds of creative things God
made man to create we probably will not
have cars that are burning fossil fuels
in heaven but I'll tell you what it does
say when an angel came to Daniel it says
being caused to fly swiftly so angels
fly and we see in Revelation I saw an
angel flying in the midst of heaven and
then you read in Isaiah that the
redeemed of the Lord will mount up with
wings like eagles so for that reason
another is we're given the ability the
belief that in heaven we're gonna be
able to fly I don't you know think we're
gonna be using wings like you know birds
necessarily but there's something that
God gives us that gives us the ability
to be transported now it says we're
gonna plant gardens and eat the fruit of
them we'll build houses so if we're
building houses and we say look I want
to build a heavenly motorcycle I don't
think God's can tell you you can't but
it's gonna probably be pretty different
than what you might imagine now Paul
says you can't imagine the things God's
prepared for those that love him
yeah and I'll make you a promise you're
not gonna be disappointed you get there
and I promise you you won't be
disappointed okay if you are I'll give
you your money back okay all right
thanks we do have a study guide talking
about heaven it's called colossal city
in space and it talks about what God is
preparing for those that love him we'll
be able to send this to anybody who asks
for it the number is 883 five six seven
four seven you can also ask if you'd
like to sign up for the free
correspondence Bibles
cool that amazing fax has or just ask
for the lesson called a colossal city in
space you might have to send it to
anybody who calls and asks annexed Kohli
is Archie listening from California arch
welcome to the program
hi pastors hi we appreciate your
ministry
my question is everyone would like to
live forever yes it will not be like it
is now
but is to believe and trust and obey God
and mouth in other words what exactly is
necessary now for us to live in heaven
forever yeah what is necessary for us to
have eternal life Christ tells us that
if we come to him if we deny ourselves
take up our cross and follow him trust
him with our lives trust him to forgive
our sins and of course first thing is
you you accept him as Savior you tell
him that you're sorry for your sins you
confess and repent of your sins
he says he'll give us the spirit and the
power to turn from our sins because we
can't do anything without Jesus without
him we can do nothing and he promises
that by faith when we first accept him
he offers us the gift of everlasting
life we through accepting them become
citizens of another Kingdom and heaven
then becomes our home and he says I've
gone to prepare a place for you and if
I've gone to prepare a place for you I
will come again and receive you unto
myself and that's John 14 so we do have
a book that goes through what is
necessary for eternal life will send you
for free and it's simply called three
steps to heaven Archie just if you call
the number we'll send it here right now
or anybody the number to Coley is 883
five six seven four seven probably the
most important question anyone can ask
what do I have to do to be saved well
the book called clearly show you from
the Bible it's called three steps to
heaven I'd like to encourage you to call
and ask for it the number is 883 five
six seven four seven or you can read it
for free online at the amazing facts
website just amazing facts dot o-r-g
Mexico Lee's Lewis listening from can I
think it's Connecticut Louis welcome to
the program
greetings pastor's penis time call a
long time listener
thank you for your ministry well
thankfully the question count thank you
sir
my question comes from Jude 1 verse 9
pastor the pastors you've taught in the
past that Michael is Jesus correct yes
and if he's Jesus why would he have to
call upon the Lord to rebuke Satan well
Jesus several times even during his
earthly ministry he willingly took a
role of submission to the Father the
Bible tells us that the father has
committed all judgment to the son the
Bible says that the father through the
son created the world and Jesus often
invokes the ultimate authority of God
the Father and you know he's even saying
really and is a known name as well you
remember in the wilderness when Jesus
was being tempted by the devil he
rebuked the devil the last temptation he
said get thee behind me and Satan had to
go of course to clear Scripture yeah so
you know just so nobody missin Durst and
by the way this is not like our pit
belief or anything the many of the Bible
reformers they looked at the
christophany sees oh there's a number of
places in the Old Testament where this
angel of the Lord with great Authority
would appear and they would say I just
preached on Samson this weekend and his
parents said we've seen God when they
saw the angel of the Lord and when
Joshua saw the angel of the Lord the
angel said take your shoes off your feet
for you are on holy ground well that's
what God said to Moses and then it tells
us that when Michael stands up a
resurrection takes place in Daniel 12 so
you you start looking at what the
authority of Michael you've got the
dragon and revelation is a symbol for
the chief of evil which is the devil
Michael is a symbol for the chief of
good which would be Christ
so many of the great reformers believe
that Jesus is not an angel
Archangel means greatest messenger Jesus
does not you know it's not a chair of or
a Seraphim but Michael means who is as
God and he is the greatest messenger and
the Lord Himself will descend from
heaven with a shout and the voice of the
Archangel that's one sentence the Lord
Himself with the voice of the Archangel
the Lord is coming with a voice of the
greatest messenger so I've got a free
book I'll send you on that it simply
says who is Michael the Archangel all
right great yes thank you thank you then
I'm gonna call for that he's 808 three
five six seven four seven you can ask to
the book called
who is Michael the Archangel one more
time 808 three five six seven four seven
if you have a Bible question a phone
line here to the studio is 800 four six
three seven two nine seven if you happen
to get a busy signal we encourage you to
call back again or just stay on the line
and somebody will get to your call our
next call is Jose listening in
California
Jose welcome to the program hi hi
pastors thank you so much for taking my
call well thank you for your patience
yes thank you my question is should I be
concerned with you know my congregation
preaching endtime prophecies what's
wrong with preaching in time prophecy no
no I might consider that they're not
preaching it oh you say they're not
preaching it yes it should I look for
another you know congregation a church
to go to because my we we are so
involved with you know the with what we
hear from you know all your messages and
other you know pastors who agree with
preaching the endtime message and that's
just I don't know if we the question is
should we look for another place to
fellowship in ways you know preaching
truth yeah the of course a pastor should
be preaching the entire Word of God so
you don't you know I preached on Sampson
this week I'd you don't always preach on
the endtime message but you don't also
want to be negative
Dean one of the great you know here we
are living on the end of time and if a
church is never saying anything about
the times in which we live that is not
healthy either you can't only preach on
intent prophecy or people don't get a
balanced diet so yeah I I would talk to
the pastor's in a loving way and maybe
write a note and say you know we would
love to hear some messages on all the
prophecies it was important to Jesus
there's a blessing pronounced on those
who read the book of Revelation and this
encourage them it and you may need to
shop around if if people are neglecting
big sections of God's Word yes yes
definitely does and will definitely keep
you know them in prayer and and you know
just so that yeah I would I definitely
agree with with what you're saying all
right well we hate we appreciate that
very much trying to think what we can
send him on prophecy yes yes we do have
a number of things of prophecy I'm
thinking probably be one of the most
important subjects that you can talk
about Bible prophecies the three angels
messages found in Revelation 14 we do
have a study guide dedicated to that and
it's called angel messages from space
kind of an intriguing name there but
that's talking about the three angels
messages we'll be happy to send it to
anybody who calls and asks again the
study guide is called angel messages
from space and we'll be happy to send
that to anyone who calls 883 five six
seven four seven the number again is 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and you can ask for the study guide
called angel messages from space and by
the way if you don't call the number but
you'd like to read the study guide for
free online just go to the amazing facts
website it's just amazing facts dot
o-r-g
and there you'll be able to read it
there as well as a number of other
important resources that we have that I
think you'll thoroughly enjoy so one
more time to get your pen handy the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the study guide called angel
messages from space our next caller that
we have is
listening in Washington Ben welcome to
the program
hello hi Ben welcome hi my question is
when they dad and a by who - unholy fire
into the sanctuary it says that fire
came out from the presence of the Lord
and devoured them and then later in the
text it says that they had men come in
to carry them out and my question is
were Naida and if I who ashes at that
point when they carried them out or you
know that's a good question
firstly it relates to you remember the
story where God had given very clear and
strict instructions through Moses as to
the the priests Aaron and his sons as to
what they were to do they were to use
special consecrated fire when they
entered into the first compartment of
the sanctuary that's where they would
offer the incense and they were also
involved in just setting aside the
sacredness of the sanctuary and a
judgment came it was a lesson to all of
Israel the Shekinah glory or the visible
presence of God was manifest in the most
holy place so most likely what happened
of course we weren't there but probably
there was a flash of light
possibly heat but the two was struck
down not so much that they were consumed
completely with fire but it was
sufficient heat or flame that took their
life they fell to the ground now this is
in the first compartment of the
sanctuary so they were on the priests
that could ain t in and remove the body
from where it was and all of that was
really just to testimony or a witness
that the work of God is sacred and there
is a high responsibility okay can I ask
you another question sure what okay in
Revelation when the fire comes down from
God out of the holy city Jerusalem do
you think the same thing happens to the
wicked that are at
backing the city there may be knocked
out and then turn to ashes after they
die
well eventually it tells us fire comes
down from God out of heaven and devoured
them so at some point the fire does
ultimately devour them and our oh how
long each person suffers may vary you
know Bible says every man is rewarded
according to what he deserves and so you
know we do have a lesson that talks
about the punishment of the wicked we'll
be happy to send you a copy it's
actually a you know I wonder if we can
send out that new magazine we have
talking about the the mystery of death
hello and everlasting life brand-new
magazine that amazing faxes just put
together and I think you can order it
online if you'd like to purchase one but
you can call and ask for it and I'm sure
we'll be able to send you one the number
to call is eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the magazine entitled the afterlife
mystery and it deals with the subject of
death we also have a study guide that
it's that's entitled other dead really
then you can ask for that we'll be happy
to send that out to anybody who calls
and asks next for there we have is Rick
listening in New Jersey Rick welcome to
the program i pastored how are you doing
doing great thank you question I have
made I have a definite answer maybe only
speculation but we know that Stephen was
the first martyr and as he was being
stoned to death he looked up into heaven
and he saw Jesus standing at the right
hand of God mm-hmm I don't know the
Bible verses but verbatim I'm a truck
driver but I don't have access right now
but isn't it before isn't Jesus referred
to as sitting at the right hand of God
and other parts of Scripture and here
he's standing at the right hand of God
with that because maybe he's taken
notice of what maybe he's got Jesus
attention and he's I'm thinking maybe
he's getting ready to walk with Jesus
into the kingdom but uh yeah let me read
that that's Acts chapter 7 and I think
you've read in verse 59 and as they were
stoning Stephen he called out Lord Jesus
receive my spirit and a wait a second
it's there standing at the right hand of
God he saw the Son of man standing at
the right hand of God
that's verse 56 yeah that is interesting
because it's it's like the Lord was
looking out for him you know there's an
maybe just you know maybe he just he's
got my full attention you know start
absolutely but I think there's a little
more to that to you'll finding Daniel
chapter 12 just bear with me for a
second Daniel 12 talks about Michael
says when Michael stands up there will
be a time of trouble that's when
probation closes for the human race
Michael is the prophetic name of Christ
something significant happened when
Stephen was stoned that was the
fulfillment of the 490 year prophecy
that you finally Daniel chapter 9
thright and in a very real sense
probation was closing for the Jewish
nation and that's of course at that
point where you have the conversion of
soul it becomes Paul and he's known as
the apostle to the Gentiles so the
gospel then spread out to the whole
world so some have seen in the fact that
Jesus was standing at that very moment
not only concerned about what's
happening to Stephen but it also
signified a close of probation for the
nation of Israel as a whole in their
little arrest of course we believe that
God's the other special work for Jewish
people and that that Jews can be saved
it doesn't mean that right but their
their purpose was to declare and
proclaim the Messiah and when Stephen
gave that last message in the Supreme
Court plug their ears it fulfilled the
prophecy that today were going to be
conquered and they were at that point
I'm not too long after that yeah we have
a lesson that talks about that don't we
they're dealing with the time of the
judgment what is that right on time
right on time yes it talks about date
for the judgment I'm sorry that's the
one okay God set the date for the judge
if you'd like to receive that Rick why
anybody the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven we'll be happy to send that to
anybody who calls an ass it's called God
set a date for the judgment next quarter
that we have is Jed listening in
Michigan Jed welcome to the program hey
good evening
good hey Jed well let's get started on
your question if we come up to the break
we'll finish it after the break okay
okay great
we've been going through the book of
mark here
and prayer me and we got to this point
in chapter 5 verse 25 about the woman
with the issue of 12 years and then down
at the end of the chapter as a young
girl here that has been healed and she
was 12 years old and so the question was
asked is there something symbolic about
this lady with the issue and this girl
of is 12 years old healed also I am so
glad you asked that question that is a
that is very perceptive and I've got a
very exciting answer for you on that
wait you can't wait but you're gonna
have to wait until after our break we're
we got a break coming up I don't even
want to start on it because I think a
break comes up in 30 seconds or about
that but it is interesting that you've
got these two women and in the middle of
Christ's ministry within a few minutes
of each other they both touch Jesus or
he touches them they're both connected
with 12 years 12 is a number that
signifies the church and when we come
back after the break I'm gonna explain
how that all ties together it is a
fascinating study so don't go anywhere
friends we're gonna be back if you have
questions give us a call 800 god says
and we're back online for our Facebook
friends at the Doug Batchelor Facebook
site talk to you in just a moment
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth com can't
get enough amazing facts Bible study you
don't have to wait until next week to
enjoy more truth filled programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aft vor G at aft vor G you can enjoy
video and audio presentations as well as
printed material all free of charge 24
hours a day seven days a week right from
your computer or mobile device visit aft
vor G for life-changing Christian
resources visit a F bookstore com every
bible question you have answered moves
you one step closer to the fullness of
God's will for your life so what are you
waiting for get the answers you need for
a fuller richer more confident life
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
the number is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven and past the deck just
before the break we were talking to Jed
he was talking about mark chapter five
yeah this is an incredible story where
you have Jesus is he's on his way
through this small town he stopped by a
man named Darius who says my daughter's
at the point of death and will you come
healer Jesus is going to raise or to
heal this young man's daughter and while
he's going he's just mobbed with people
on every side and this one woman who's
been bleeding for 12 years which would
render her unclean in the Bible she has
faith that if she could just touch the
hem of His garment she'll be healed and
this another place I read in the Bible
where it says many believes if they
could just touch the hem of his clothes
he they they'd be healed she was one of
them and Jesus stops and says who
touched me she tells the whole story
then he goes from that experience and he
touches this girl who is by this point
died she's 12 years old he raises her to
life it's telling us I believe in Bible
symbols a woman represents a church here
you have Christ who is the central axis
of the Old Testament and New Testament
churches the Old Testament there was a
continual flow of blood of the animals
but they didn't get any better and they
weren't saved by the blood of animals
until they touched Jesus the cross when
Jesus bled for them and then you've got
this little girl who looks like she's
dead when Christ died they thought the
church was done for but he resurrects
her at the resurrection the church was
brought back to life and she's 12 years
old 12 is a number for the church you
get a woman in Revelation chapter 12
with 12 crowns twelve stars rather above
her head and he got the twelve tribes
and the 12 judges and the 12 apostles
and the New Jerusalem is 12,000 furlongs
12 is a number for the church and so
this is a wonderful story in the middle
of the Gospels talking about how the Old
Testament they were saved by looking
forward in faith to Christ the New
Testament are saved by looking back to
Christ those two women represent like
Ruth and Naomi the old and the new that
both nursed obut and it's just a
wonderful story
Jake you there yes did that make some
sense wonderfully oh yeah great I can
use that I just want you guys to know
that we really appreciate you here in
Michigan well thank you I'll be at the
Michigan camp meeting and the Great
Lakes Academy this summer I think pastor
Ross is there - we're gonna we'll look
forward to seeing you yeah another great
all right god bless you bye-bye next
caller that we have I believe he's Larry
listening in Tennessee Larry you there
yes it's Laurie Laurie hi Laurie welcome
hi my question is will the church be
raptured out mid-tribulation
and could that be any day well there are
a lot of dear Christians that are on all
three parts of the timing I want to just
make that really clear some Christians
believe that the the second coming that
the Christians are caught up before the
tribulation some believe it's after
three and a half years in the middle of
the tribulation and some believe the
tribulation comes before we are caught
up I am of the group that believes that
the tribulation comes before and the
reason is Jesus says he that endures to
the end will be saved a God Paul said it
is through tribulation we enter the
kingdom of God you can also see in the
Bible that it tells us that God saved
the children of Israel well the seven
last plagues you see in Revelation they
are the Great Tribulation it's pretty
clear that you know that's when
everything is falling apart and then you
also have the children of Israel we're
in Egypt when the ten plagues fell on
Egypt that's interesting that they were
protected from the seven last plagues
which are similar similar to the seven
plagues you find in Revelation and so we
believe the tribulation comes first and
then it says at that time Daniel chapter
12 there'll be a great time of trouble
such as there never has been and at that
time thy people will be delivered
everyone found written in the book and
many of those that sleep in the dust of
the earth shall awake well that's when
the
word descends from heaven with a shout
the dead in Christ rise then that was
first Thessalonians 4 so I do have a
book I can send you a free copy on that
glory that's called anything but secret
that talks about the timing of the
tribulation connected with the the
second coming and being caught up to
meet the Lord you there ask for the book
anything but secret we'll send you a
free copy just got a call this one
number yes the number to call is 808
three five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the book called anything but
secret that number once again is 808
three five six seven four seven annex
call like calling from Texas roll roll
welcome to the program
hey going good thanks for calling thanks
for thanks for doing this and your
question tonight so my question is um
what's the best way to go about when you
reading the Bible to know if what's
being written is specifically for the
people at that time or if it's something
of this like a cultural thing or if it's
something that we actually need to apply
to our line well good question of course
everything should be read in its context
but all of the Bible is written for
everybody to learn from for instance
when Noah told people get on the ark a
flood is coming well we learned from
that about the last days who Jesus said
it'll be like the days of Noah now you
and I are not supposed to build a boat
and get on it so that was a specific
message that was present truth for them
but we do definitely learn from that
lesson so there's a number of things in
the Bible that were specific messages to
a specific time but we all learn from
there's lessons in those histories and
in those statements now you asked
another question are some things
cultural but yeah there there are you
know one of the common questions we get
is regarding first Corinthians where it
says it's a shame for a woman to pray
with her head uncovered and a lot of
there's only one verse that says that
but we get a lot of questions well is it
wrong for a woman to have short hair or
must a woman always wear a head covering
her hat or bonnet in church and you
probably know as we do
there are many sincere Christians that
do where the women all wearing hats I
frankly think that was a cultural custom
I have no problem with a person
believing differently I mean there's
certainly no harm in it but because you
don't find the scripture mentioned in
more than one spot you you think Paul is
really talking to the Corinthian church
there you know what I'm saying so that
would be more of a cultural thing but
he's got great lessons in there about
headship talks about God being the head
of every man and so the lessons are
still there even when there's a cultural
message our tradition you still with me
yeah yeah I'm here yeah it is that
making sense yeah it makes sense
it's just that is there a specific place
you're wondering about where you're
wondering is this a tradition or is this
for all of us um there's just like
specific topics that have kind of popped
up in my mind it just makes things
uncertain unclear about other things
yeah well there there are some things
that were cultural some commandments are
very explicit in the Bible and you know
God's Word doesn't change in that
respect and whenever you're in doubt do
the safe thing and yeah if you if you've
got doubts Bible says anything not of
faith is sin do do the safe thing and
follow your convictions follow the Word
of God and then you'll just tell the
Lord when he comes look Lord and set it
right here so I did it and you have no
problem thank you for your call we
appreciate that very much roll next one
of there we have is Melora listening
from Virginia Melora welcome to the
program hi alright I was wondering when
is it appropriate to center a church
member I mean what kind of behaviors
weren't such a measure well you know
there can be a spectrum of thing
in different churches of course in
different denominations have kind of
different policies in our church you
know there may it be a person who's had
a moral fall and you you don't want them
to stop coming but they're really not in
the position to be holding office some
churches will say look of a couple's
going through divorce one of them might
have biblical grounds one may not
probably not a good time for them to be
holding a public position in the church
because it just you know they first of
all don't need that if a person is
creating division in a church through
all kinds of gossip and contentious
behavior Paul says you know don't bear
with those people at some point you need
to warn them with censure and they might
need to be eventually put out of the
church and then of course there's
there's gross sins if a person is living
in some kind of high-handed sin 1st
Corinthians I forget what the verses
pastor also that man was living with his
stepmother evidently Paul said what's
wrong with you telling their Corinthian
church you need to kick him out he was
becoming a it was that culture the
pagans were making fun of the Christians
they said look at what they're doing and
they don't stand for anything so that
gives a bad name to the church
and so you know there's a pretty broad
list I could start listening all kinds
of sins here but that's just some
examples things that would really be
bringing reproach on the Lord or an open
violation to one of the commandments it
doesn't report on the Lord yeah on if
someone is doing something that is
bringing reproach on the name of the
Lord then they might need 'no century is
different than being disfellowship
center is sort of like a probation and a
warning you're wanting to redeem them
you're not kicking them out of the
church but you're saying you know until
you get this cleaned up our little time
needs to go by before we put you back
into some position of visibility that's
typically the way censure is used but
you know it rarely happens do you mind
my asking why you're asking well we're
having this division in our church over
one man doesn't like the pastor and the
pastor doesn't like him and
I think the pastor's using his position
to make things more difficult for the
for the parishioner and it's just awful
yeah that's the devil tries to bring in
division and and you know sometimes
they'll you know I'm a pastor and I
think there are pastors that have abused
their authority but I think there times
a pastor needs to say if you've got a
contentious member that will not respect
the leadership that's been chosen by the
church and even though that leadership
may not be perfect at some point you
know you just if someone has to submit
and it you have to take action so it can
get it can get unpretty I'm wondering
you know we do have a study guide that
talks about how to survive in church
it's actually a book I wrote called how
to survive in church I think we can send
you a copy and I'm gonna call for that
he's 808 three five six seven four seven
you can ask to the book how to survive
in church again the number is 885 six
seven four seven next one that we have
is Cheryl listening from New York
Cheryl welcome to the program hi hi girl
thanks for calling yes thank you for
taking my call okay um I'm not a Bible
scholar but I read it and listen in
church and I have a question in
different places it says to be absent
with the rule to be absent from the body
is to be present with the Lord then
somewhere else it says to be asleep in
Christ then in Revelation it says the
second the second resurrection he shall
judge the dead so what when do you die
and just go to heaven did your spirit
just go to heaven or are you always
asleep waiting who's to say who gets
judged and stays asleep if I'm reading
it right you're a great question let me
just dive in here that you're asking a
question that's a very perceptive
question people read these different
verses and they go what in the world and
they walk through a church cemetery and
you'll have one tombstone it will say
our mother is singing with the Angels
and the next tombstone will say our
is resting in peace here's where the
confusion comes in the Bible says to be
absent from the body is to be present
with the Lord when you die you think
with your brain your brain dies too yeah
when the Lord comes he resurrects you
and you get a new glorified body between
the time when you die in the Lord
resurrects you you have no consciousness
of time and your next thought is the
presence of the Lord but the
resurrection doesn't happen til the Lord
comes is very clear 1st Thessalonians 4
says the Lord will descend from heaven
with a shout the voice of the Archangel
the Trump of God then the dead in Christ
will rise first Corinthians 15 says the
dead on Christ will rise at his coming
Jesus said the judgment in the
resurrection are the last day so that's
called the day of the Lord that's when
they're raised but for a Christian who
dies they may have died a thousand years
ago for them it's some a moment the
twinkling of an eye and the next thing
if you're saved
well even if you're lost you're next
thing is a resurrection of the the
doomed which is terrible but so because
there's no consciousness in death
the Bible says the living know they'll
die this is Ecclesiastes 9 the dead know
not anything I think King David said
those that go down into the grave do not
praise the Lord Jesus said Lazarus is
asleep they're gonna be judged and the
second resurrection or but like I've
been a Christian for since 1979 I read
the scriptures I try to be good and I
just is my spirit just gonna go to
heaven or am I gonna be asleep in Christ
waiting for judgment - well you will
have if you die believing your next
thought is to come out of the grave it
may seem like a five seconds to you or
less it's gonna be a twinkling of an eye
now let me give you an example Acts
chapter 2 Peters preaching he talks
about King David this is that great
famous King David there's only one David
in the Bible there's one that killed the
Giant a man after God's own heart he is
saved here's what Peter says Peter says
David is dead
and buried and not ascended to heaven so
David's gonna be you know David died
3,000 years ago for us but it doesn't
seem like that to us the Bible's the
David slept with his father's he's been
sleeping a dreamless sleep I kind of
knew I was sleeping last night because I
had crazy dreams but when you don't even
dream it seems like no time has gone by
boom you're with the Lord so you know
this last week that great man Billy
Graham passed away and everybody had him
up in heaven talking with God and doing
all these things well technically he's
not there yet for him it will be the
next thing he experiences but the
resurrection hasn't happened so can I
send you a free study please on this
subject and she would enjoy that new
magazine we talked about absolutely it's
called the afterlife mystery we'll be
able to send that to you Cheryl or you
can also ask if you can't get that
magazine right away we do have a study
guide called
odd the dead rarely dead and it deals
with this very subject gives you a lot
of Bible truths
I'll read it free online yeah just go to
the amazing facts website amazing facts
dot o R G the number to call if you'd
like us to mail that to you is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven eight hundred eight thirty five
sixty seven forty seven as for the study
guide are the dead really dead hey
Cheryl let me jump in you got a pencil
you got a pencil
yeah but character says if you're
cremated what happens you'll still be
resurrected because you're not using the
old body God's giving you a brand new
body there's a sermon online if you want
to see something you go to youtube and
type in the Witch of Endor Doug
Batchelor just type in Doug Batchelor
The Witch of Endor and it'll bring up a
sermon I did on the very question you're
asking and thank you so much for your
call
we've got Fred listening in Michigan
Fred welcome to the program thank you
what I want to in the chapter thirteen
of Revelation my interpretation is that
that's a time period from when we left
Europe the Reformation so on tear is it
right down to the mark the very end
and with one slap news chapter 30 verse
13 we note the father come down from
heaven in the earth in the sight of men
I've come to believe that that's because
that's where America was settled and at
a lamb and we end up speaking like a
lion and the meaning that is electricity
are you sorry you wanting is your
question what does the fire coming down
from heaven mean that because I were
sick sick sick and Hebrew is www.and to
me when I want what electricity as a man
to get electricity and the soldier that
by the wonders and by the the deceived
people to me that's that's TV that's
rock and roll as pornography that's just
you know everything all in the air or
everything that comes from electricity
an ordinary group thinks but by and
large to me that's what that represent
you know it's interesting
let me tell you something that goes
along with that because you got to turn
this into a question pretty quick but it
is interesting the first electronic
message was sent in 1844 by Samuel Morse
did you know that yeah that was Morse
code but anyway let me jump in because
we're gonna run out of time we want to
be able to answer your question the fire
coming down from heaven when you
understand something to the Bible
compare Scripture with Scripture in the
Old Testament you have a case where God
brought fire down from heaven BrahMos
as' fire came down from heaven when
Elijah prayed fire came down from heaven
when the sacrifice was offered by
Solomon and that fire often represents
the power of God that fire came down
from heaven as actually God came up in
the fire with Samson mm-hmm
tongues of fire in Acts chapter 2 yeah
it's often a symbol of God's power but
the devil can bring fire down from
heaven he does in the book of Job and so
it's like in the last days Satan is
gonna counterfeit the power of God but
it's intriguing what you said about
electricity we are deaf
living from the time of Laodicea we're
living in the last stage of the church
it is a time where there's electric fire
power I'd never thought of that before
which is increased it says yeah in the
Book of Daniel absolutely you know we
have a study that talks about revelation
13 we'll be happy to send you a free
copy and now is that the one that is
that's the one that talks about the
United States in prophecy the USA in
prophecy yes no chapter 13 the number
the coal to receive that is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you can ask for the United States
in prophecy I'll be happy to send it to
anybody who calls and asks next quarter
that we have is Jody listening from
Texas Jody you on Bible answers live yes
sir hey god bless you guys y'all did a
great job and I really like how you guys
answer questions I've got a quick
question I was always wondered on at the
Red Cross when Jesus was dying and he
mentioned why God had forsaken him I
never understood that and it's probably
pretty common but yeah that's a good
question and when I first read that I
thought wait a second I thought Jesus
never sinned and here it sounds like he
lost faith what's going on here or that
he got discouraged but really if you
look Psalm 22 is what they call one of
the Messianic Psalms Psalm 22 begins
with my God my God why have you forsaken
me and pastor Ross can look it up I
forget what verse it is but later in
that same sum it says they cast lots for
my clothing they pierced my hands and my
feet that dogs have encompassed me that
Psalm describes the scenes of the cross
so when Christ called out he was quoting
a verse everything Jesus did was Bible
even from the cross he's quoting from a
psalm that points to his sacrifice Psalm
22 verse 1 my God my God why have you
forsaken me and later in that Psalm it
talks about they pierced my hands and my
feet I forget what verse it is and dogs
have encompassed me and they cast lots
from my clothing and it's a psalm that
talks about the the very sufferings of
Jesus on the cross yep even look in
verse 14 describes that
sixteen verse 17 though 16 says they
piss my hands my feet for 17 I can count
all my bones they look and stare at me
they divide my garments them so this
could be one reason the thief on the
cross he heard Jesus quote that he knew
that verse from a child and all of a
sudden he looks he sees everything in
that in that Psalm is happening before
his very eyes so that exactly he was
pointing to what that Psalm meant yeah
and you know it's also a rhetorical
question why have you forsaken me jesus
knew I got it forsaken him he's asking
everyone to know Christ was like Isaiah
53 the father would through his
protection from him because he bore our
sins so he's kind of asking a rhetorical
question in that psalm and pointing them
to those prophecies of the crucifixion
hey thank you I like that question next
for that we have a Jim listen II in Ohio
Jim welcome to the program oh thank you
for your patience yeah no problem I was
wondering about the two witnesses you
know that's supposed to be at the end
times in Revelations yeah
and revelation 11 yeah and back in like
in Abraham's time and lot and in Jesus
you know when he rose from the grave
rivers there was these two you know that
talked to Abraham yeah I talking about
when Moses and Elijah appeared and yeah
let me jump in before we run out of time
you're on the right track Moses appeared
to Jesus Moses was resurrected you read
in the book of Jude Elijah went to
heaven and a fiery chariot they
represent the law and the prophets the
commandments of God and the testimony of
Jesus they are a symbol of the two
witnesses meaning that the Word of God
the law and the prophets were testifying
that Jesus was the one they all pointed
to and so this was a fulfillment of that
we have a book we can give you on that
subject and it is called the two
witnesses the you know it's called the
glorious mount it's the two way
this isn't if you just call we'll send
you a free copy that anyone that wants
to understand that magnificent passage
and who the two witnesses are asked for
this free book the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again the book is called
the two witnesses the glorious mount
just ask for that and we'll vampa to
send it to anybody who calls and asks
well you know pass it up there's some
exciting things happening at amazing
facts I know we have some listeners
around the world but you and I will be
getting on a plane tomorrow to head over
the India for a couple weeks that's
right we've got people all across India
that watch the programs we're gonna go
visit I think we'll be in two or three
cities over there yes and in Dubai in
the Middle East
but the program here will continue and
make sure and check out the amazing
facts YouTube site we got hundreds of
sermons there and you can go to our
website amazing facto RG
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control well you're
hit with something new your marriage
your job your health you could look to
the stars but they don't know the
answers but this does the prophecy study
Bible by amazing facts
it's 27 personal study guides lead you
on a life-changing journey get yours
today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AAF
bookstore com can't get enough amazing
facts Bible study you don't have to wait
until next week to enjoy more truth
filled programming visit the amazing
facts media library at aft vor G at aft
vor G you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word visit our web
site at WWF AG 0 RG and sign up for our
free Bible study course and make sure to
check out our online bookstore at AF
bookstore calm which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at